This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we have a listener requested episode for you all, one that a couple of you actually wrote in and DMed me about after our 20s. toxic friendship episode. In that episode, we talked about the victim friend. And it brought up a lot of questions about the victim, the broader victim mentality that we spoke about in that episode. And what psychology actually says about people who always play the victim? I fell down such a rabbit hole of information about this, about this idea, this phenomena, this concept. And so today,
here we are, we are going to dive into the complex psychology behind the victim mentality. Now, I want to start with a very important note. When I talk about the victim mentality, I'm not trying to minimize the experiences of people who have genuinely been victimized by abuse, by systemic injustice, by trauma, by loss. If you have been through something that's left your body and your brain on constant high alert, if you've learned through experiences that bad things do happen to you more than others, you are not a problem or the problem that we are unpacking today. What we are talking about is a pattern of behavior or a psychological habit
whereby people turn neutral situations or situations that simply don't go their way into something that they use to gain sympathy from others for their own. for their own gain. We're talking about situations where people learn how to turn out natural sympathy against us in a way that feels manipulative, icky, wrong, in a way that really lacks self-awareness. So the question we're really asking today is how do we navigate these kinds of people, whether they're friends, family members, colleagues, how do we navigate people who truly do believe that everything goes wrong for them, that everybody is out to get them, that they are the
unluckiest person in the world, and why are they the way they are? What made them this way? Do they genuinely have any clarity about what they're doing? And yeah, how do you go about it so that you aren't always in the firing line? Without further ado, I am so excited for this episode. Let's get into the psychology behind the victim mentality. First of all, how does the first of all, how does the field of psychology talk about this phenomena. So in psychology, the term victim mentality or victim mindset, it's also known as that, it basically refers to a habitual pattern of thought in which a person consistently perceives themselves as a victim of the negative actions of others or of fate, even when the evidence suggests otherwise. That second half of that statement is the
most crucial part, the evidence suggests otherwise. And as one 2020 study put it, across all situations, even when outcomes differ, these people will still seek out an explanation where they are the victim. That is the one constant in every situation. They are always the one who is wronged, even when things change, even again when the evidence is stacked up against them, even when people tell them, no, you're wrong. The victim mentality is actually believed to be somewhat of a personality trait. We all have the capacity to see ourselves as less or more as a victim, you know, regardless of actual circumstances. But people high in this victim trait tend to, again, interpret neutral or ambiguous situations
or events as hostile. They tend to dwell on unfair treatment and ruminate longer than others. and they really struggle to move past what happened, meaning that everything that maybe does prove this mentality or does prove this state of mind for them gets held onto longer than any situations that don't. It isn't that they're lying. They do truly believe that the world is against them.
They're suffering from a delusion, a delusion of victimhood. I used to have a co-worker just like this. I'm not going to give any more specifics than that because they do still work at this place. But any time, like somebody got a promotion, they would always turn it into about, into about like how nothing good ever happened to them. Anytime someone gave feedback, they were bullying her. They were ganging up on her. One time, one of our co-workers won, do you know those car giveaways that they sometimes have
at supermarkets or like malls where you can like win a Kia carnival or like win a Suzuki Swift like one time one of our co-workers won one of those competitions and I remember she went on and on about how you know if she'd won the car which of course she wouldn't probably you know wouldn't even work anyways I bet it would be a scam this reality of her having won the car didn't even exist and yet she had turned a situation that had not happened that was not real into one in which she was still the victim. And it wasn't even her life or her story. And I remember like that happening and being like, oh, I actually feel really bad for you. Because imagine like every possible scenario, even those that haven't occurred, still end up in the same way when you haven't even
given them the opportunity to prove you otherwise. It would be a pretty sad way to live. There are a few key signs that someone you're dealing with has this kind of victim mindset. Number one, the biggest of them all, they externalize blame. They attribute their struggles, their faults, their mistakes entirely to others or to fate or to bad luck. In psychology, there is this idea that people either have. have an internal or external locus of control. This was a theory that was developed in the 1950s biophysicologist called Julian Roder. Basically what he said is if you have an external locus, you see your life as being controlled by outside forces that you have no control over. So you shouldn't
bother trying to change anything because these forces are always going to win. If, on the other hand, you have an internal locus of control, you basically believe that you make your own luck. You can influence your life. You can kind of guess which mentality the victim tends to have, the external locus, right? So that is why blame is never something that they take on. It's always about the outside world, outside circumstances, things that they have no capacity to control. Number two, and this might surprise you, but this mentality often makes the person feel morally superior and act that way as well. So in that 2020 paper I mentioned earlier, researchers actually found that people high in victimhood also show high levels of moral elitism, which is basically a belief that they've been wronged and as such they have a moral high ground.
This can make them feel as though they're entitled to more from life. They're entitled to more sympathy. They're entitled to more leniency. They are allowed to retaliate because they see themselves as fundamentally righteous because of what has happened to them. In daily life, you know, how might this look? It might look like someone who constantly is like, well, you know, I'm going to steal that thing from the grocery store because when I was a kid, like I never, I never, I never. got much or, you know, I expect you to rescue me. Like, I can't possibly be responsible for dealing with this situation or they resist taking steps towards change. They might say that they
want help, but it has to be on their terms. And anytime you try to suggest something, they normally reject it. They feel entitled for more from you. They feel entitled to your resources, your time, your energy, because it's owed to them by their bad luck. by their bad circumstances. The third sign, someone has a victim mindset. They are also very self-centered. They constantly bring the conversation back to them. They lack empathy for other people's suffering.
In fact, they see other people's suffering as an inconvenience to their own ability to talk about their suffering. And they also really do tend to dramatize, overstate, maybe even lie. about experiences or events that they've been through in order to get attention. Although they see the world as controlling their fate, they also still have a lot and a deep sense of self-focus, and they tend to think about themselves more than other people do, and more than they think about others,
which is honestly fine. Like, you should be your number one priority. But for people with the victim mindset, it's the only priority. Now, this brings us to a big question. How do people end up like this? How do two people who have the same childhoods end up like this? How do two people who grew up in the same city, country, circle of friends, and, you know, how do they end up so that one of them takes accountability, one of them doesn't?
Some of us are able to celebrate successes. Other people can't stop complaining about how hard done by they are. The core truth, and maybe one that's a little bit uncomfortable, is that it usually starts as protection. At its core, the victim mentality reflects a psychological position of learned helplessness. This was a concept first proposed by Martin Selkman in the 1970s. We've mentioned it on the podcast a few times before, but essentially what he found was that when people don't feel like they can escape their bad circumstances, even when they are clearly given a route or an opportunity to do so, they still won't take it because they have learnt that nothing they do matters. They have no control
because in the past they've had no control. Let me be clear, for many people, it's not an act. It's not even necessarily a conscious behavior. Instead, it's actually, you know, often a functional freeze response, a way the brain protects itself after prolonged helplessness, prolonged trauma, prolonged invalidation. Through a trauma lens, if we're having sympathy for these people, it makes a lot of sense when someone experiences chronic maltreatment, when they've experienced emotional abuse or neglect or repeated failure from their relationships in some form or from the system, their nervous system learns that agency is pointless and the body goes into what trauma therapist
Stephen Porgis calls the dorsal vagal state it's basically a state of shutdown dissociation freeze and in that state the message the brain is sending constantly is you're not safe and you can't do anything about it don't fight don't move don't run away Over time, the physiological reaction can kind of crystallize into a psychological identity, aka, I'm the person who bad things happen to. I can't do anything about this. Here's where the story gets a little bit more layered. Yes, it does start as a protective strategy most of the time,
but it can also take on manipulative qualities, especially when it develops into what we call covert narcissism. Covert narcissism, it's also called vulnerable narcissism, is a subtype of narcissistic personality disorder or narcissistic personality patterns that hides behind insecurity, shame, and self-pity, rather than arrogance. So unlike the classic, grandiose narcissist who demands admiration, the covert narcissist seeks someone to rescue them and give them validation and reassurance through their suffering.
There was a 2024 paper published in the Journal of Social and Personality Psychology, and it found that covert narcissists don't necessarily dominate rooms. They don't come in hot, they don't need people to think they're the best, but they do seek to elicit a caring response from others that actually, inevitably ends up dominating the emotional undertones of a space. Their pain becomes the currency through which they maintain control over a situation, over their relationships, over how other people see them. Now, because empathy is one of the strongest human instincts,
this strategy often works really well for a while. People rush into help. We want to comfort, we want to re-assure this person. and we don't want them to suffer. And this person loves that because it does feel amazing. But soon those relationships do start to feel one way. They start to feel like transactions. And of course, naturally people are going to drop off.
People are going to leave that person's life. That actually increases their attempts for victimhood and their idea of themselves as a victim, as somebody that people leave, as somebody that people can't love, not tracing it back to this pattern of behavior that they're exhibiting. Still, it's important to note that even manipulative forms of victimhood usually began as legitimate pain. The difference is that the person never learned how to self-soothe or regulate,
so they just externalize that responsibility onto others. They learnt that helplessness gets them what assertiveness never did. And this passive state is again, it is reinforced by early experiences. Early experiences of not being heard, but noticing that actually when you play up the powerlessness, when you exacerbate or, you know, really call in people to try and comfort you and help you, you get the same kind of love that you probably wanted all along. Ultimately, I think knowing this helps us hold kind of two truths at the same time. Some people live from a place of victimhood because life taught them to.
Others use victimhood because it gives them power. Both need compassion. I think the sentiment is that only one of them can truly heal. The first kind where it's really just because of an absence of love and an absence of feeling like they can take control of their life. That one is something people can get over. When they have crossed into the state of like, this is actually a really great way to get what I want from people and get what I want
from situations, it's a lot harder, if not almost impossible after a while to come back from that. Now, I'm sure at this point, if you've listened this far, you probably have somebody in mind who you are thinking of. Maybe it's your mother. maybe it's a friend of yours, maybe it's a family member, maybe it's like a colleague, maybe it's even your partner. And the thing is, is that you can have sympathy for this person.
You can understand that this mindset was born from a deep pain and still be deeply frustrated by how it impacts you. So what I really want to talk about next is what do we do when this kind of individual is in our life, sucking energy from us, how do we handle this in a way that doesn't just further determine or prove their victimhood to them? We're going to talk about that after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our show.
strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversational. with so many incredible guests.
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took
an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends,
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh hell no. I vowed.
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that we can all admit, I think pretty freely,
being around someone who is always a victim is exhausting. It is exhausting. It's boring. It's annoying. Like, yeah, those might, we might not want to admit that, but it's true. Even if you have sympathy for them, even if you understand why they are the way they are, relationships run on reciprocity. Both people have to share emotional labor. Both people have to take responsibility.
Both people have to feel like they are seen as much as they are seeing. You know what I mean? That doesn't change even if you know. that someone is incapable of doing that, even if you know why they are the way they are. And over time, I think it makes us feel like we aren't family members. We aren't friends with this person. We aren't truly a partner to this person. We are a caretaker.
There is this underlying dynamic of like, you need me more than I need you, that really can ruin a partnership and ruin a relationship. Do you want to know something else really interesting? Maybe. Maybe not interesting. Maybe kind of hard. The closer you get to someone like this, the kinder you actually are to them, the more you do try to tolerate it, the worse their behavior has actually become. In a lot of literature, including from psychologists like Judith Herman, who is a huge trauma expert, she wrote the foundational work, trauma and recovery.
What she describes is that trauma survivors who end up having a victim mindset do often oscillate between craving closeness and really fearing it. And so they often will begin to victimize themselves as a victim of you in your presence as a way to push away the love that they so crave and also are so fearful of. The more as well that they that they trust you, the less they will suppress these urges towards victimhood. The closer you get, the more you see these patterns, the more you actually might. not want to be around them so you pull away, the more it confirms to this person that they are in fact a victim, the more they ramp up the victim mentality. It's a terrible cycle. It's very unfair. It's very messy. And, you know, for you, it's really difficult because no matter how much reassurance or patients you offer, it may never be registered as safety if the other person's nervous
What she describes is that trauma survivors who end up having a victim mindset do often oscillate between craving closeness and really fearing it. And so they often will begin to victimize themselves as a victim of you in your presence as a way to push away the love that they so crave and also are so fearful of. The more as well that they that they trust you, the less they will suppress these urges towards victimhood. The closer you get, the more you see these patterns, the more you actually might. not want to be around them so you pull away, the more it confirms to this person that they are in fact a victim, the more they ramp up the victim mentality. It's a terrible cycle. It's very unfair. It's very messy. And, you know, for you, it's really difficult because no matter how much reassurance or patience you offer, it may never be registered as safety if the other person's nervous
system is wired constantly to anticipate harm or if this has in fact become a deeply ingrained part of their personality and you know what it also really sucks let's just say it to be trying really hard with this person to have endless sympathy and then occasionally to have them turn on you and blame you blame you for their hurt blame you for their circumstances blame you or see your wins or your success as just something that further hurts them and proves that they are hard done by. And, you know, if you're somebody who was naturally optimistic and I know I am, it honestly feels contagious to be around somebody like this. Being around that kind of constant pessimism or that powerlessness can drain even the most empathetic, care for.
grass is green where you order it kind of individual because empathy by nature involves emotional mirroring we feel what others feel so when you're sitting in front of somebody there's a mirror up to your soul and all they're giving you is like this sucks this is hopeless we have no control life is hard upon us god you're going to feel that despair almost as deeply as they do the work here for anyone on either side of this patent, it's not about blame. It's about awareness. It's about an ability to recognize that reactivity and that negativity in those moments and know that it isn't about this relationship. It's about the original relationships, the relationships with parents, caregivers, with community, with the system. It's really important to know that this isn't actually about
you. It has nothing to do with you. You are just a proxy for so much other baggage and so many things that are going on behind the scenes that is just getting taken out on you. Let's shift the focus a little bit. I'm going to ask you to be completely honest and self-reflective with me for this next part, because it's one thing to talk about people who seem to live in the victim mindset. It's another to maybe recognize the moments when we may or may not. slip into that way of thinking ourselves. It's normal to have certain periods where you're just like, this really sucks. Life really sucks. You've been through a breakup. You got laid off. This has been a string of disappointments. Suddenly it feels like the world is stacked against you. I've had this happen
recently. You know, I had a huge opportunity that I've been working on for years full through recently. And, you know, it was just such a bummer. And then I had a couple days where I'm packing up, you know, my life to move countries and things aren't going right and then, you know, someone is, it's just like a bunch of things and you're just like, God, wo is me. This just all sucks. Life is terrible. And I was in the studio the other day recording with my friend Roshin and she was like, you know, she really was just like, tough love, your life's not that hard.
And I was like, yeah, totally right. Thank you for saying that to me. Like, thank you for just being like, it could be a lot. lot worse, not in a way that was like meant to undermine, but in a way that we're good friends and she could really see that like, I was just getting into this spiral. And it's comforting. It's sometimes comforting to be like, yeah, you know, life just sucks for me right now because it removes the burden of choice. It removes the burden of having to change. And this actually means that you feel a lot more free. And you feel like you don't actually have to take responsibility.
and that's great. That's actually quite a nice feeling when we're in our 20s, when we're in our 30s and it just feels like everything is suddenly our responsibility. Wouldn't it be nice if these, all these bad things that are happening to me are just not in my control at all? Psychologists actually have a name for this. It's called self-handicapping. And I wanted to include the original term for you guys.
I don't love the language of like self-handicapping. I like to use the term self-sabotaging. it basically refers to this idea that we create explanations for our setbacks that protect our self-esteem. You know, this opportunity I didn't get, it's very easy to say like, well, it's because, you know, of this and that and outside factors and these people were biased and, you know, this person, that person, it's a lot harder to say maybe because I wasn't prepared. maybe because, you know, I didn't put my best foot forward. These stories aren't conscious lies, you know. Yeah, maybe the explanation is a lot more varied. Maybe it's a combination of external and internal factors.
我不喜欢自我设障这种说法。我喜欢用自我破坏这个词。它基本上是指这样一种观念：我们为自己的挫折寻找借口，来保护我们的自尊。你知道的，这个机会我没得到，很容易就会说，哦，这是因为，你知道的，因为这个那个，还有外部因素，这些人有偏见，你知道的，这个人，那个人，要说也许是因为我没有准备好，那就难得多。也许是因为，你知道的，我没有全力以赴。这些故事并不是有意识的谎言，你知道的。是的，也许解释要多样得多。也许是外部和内部因素共同作用的结果。
But when we only look at the external factor, we shield our ego, we shield our self-esteem. We also don't have any way to grow. And we don't actually learn the truth about what we could be doing to, ask for what we want, to change our lives, to see positive changes in our attitude. If you notice that your inner monologue sounds like things never work out for me. People constantly let me down. Nobody does for me what I do for them. It might not mean that the world is against you. It might mean that you're actually repeating patterns that are quite hurtful. Sometimes our brain uses very global, wide-reaching statements to disguise a very specific
但当我们只看外部因素时，我们是在保护我们的自我，保护我们的自尊。我们也失去了任何成长的途径。我们其实并没有真正了解事实的真相，了解我们本可以做些什么来争取我们想要的东西，来改变我们的生活，来看到我们态度的积极转变。如果你注意到你的内心独白听起来像是事情从来没有对我有过好结果。人们总是让我失望。没有人像我对他们那样对过我。这可能并不意味着全世界都在与你作对。这可能意味着你实际上在重复一些非常具有破坏性的模式。有时我们的大脑会使用非常普遍、范围广泛的陈述来掩盖一种非常具体的
kind of grief. Saying everyone leaves me is easier than admitting, you know, someone has left me and it really hurts and this has happened before and I don't want to investigate why. Saying nobody ever puts into my relationship what I put into it or nobody ever. ever gives me what I give them. You know, it's a lot easier to say that than to, you know, get into a conversation of like, am I people pleasing for others or for me? Am I actually a nice person? Or do I expect things in return? Maybe I should stop putting that resentment on others. Hard truths, I know maybe they're not the thing you wanted to hear. But personally, I just believe that we grow when we leave room for the truth and for and room for investigating and being honest with ourselves about
悲伤。说“每个人都离开了我”比承认“你知道的，有人离开了我，这真的很痛，而且以前也发生过，我不想去探究原因”要容易得多。说“从来没有人像我付出那么多那样投入到我的感情中”或者“从来没有人，从来没有人给我我给他们的东西”。你知道的，说这话比去探讨诸如“我是在讨好别人还是为了我自己？我真的是个好人吗？还是我在期待回报？”这样的对话要容易得多。也许我应该停止把这种怨恨转嫁给别人。我知道，这些是残酷的真相，也许它们不是你想听到的。但就我个人而言，我只是相信，当我们为真相留出空间，为探究以及诚实面对自我留出空间时，我们才会成长。
why we feel the way we feel about our circumstances. And that doesn't mean blaming yourself for what's out of your control. It means recognizing the places where you do have agency, even the tiniest bit, and using it. It's really common for people to switch between two polar opposites, blame or shame. It's either all their fault. or it's all my fault. The goal here is the middle ground. We want to be able to recognize something hurtful happened, but I still have choices now. Yes, I wish the hurtful thing hadn't happened.
为什么我们对自己的处境会有这样的感觉。这并不意味着把超出你控制范围的事情归咎于自己。这意味着认清你确实拥有自主权的那些地方，哪怕是最微小的一点，并去利用它。人们在两个极端之间摇摆是非常普遍的，那就是责备或羞耻。要么全都是他们的错，要么全都是我的错。这里的目标是找到一个折中点。我们希望能够认识到发生了令人痛苦的事情，但我现在仍然有选择。是的，我希望那件痛苦的事没有发生。
I wish life had been different. That doesn't change what's available to me in this moment. It's very tempting to believe on the flip side that empowerment means pretending nothing bad ever happens, but in the real world, sometimes it does. And we have to understand that we're allowed to move forward past that without making it our whole story. We're still acknowledging, like, this terrible thing happened. I don't want it to happen to other people.
我希望生活能有所不同。但这并没有改变此时此刻我所拥有的选择。从反面来看，很容易让人以为赋权意味着假装从未发生过任何坏事，但在现实世界中，坏事有时确实会发生。我们必须明白，我们可以超越这一点继续前进，而不必把它变成我们的全部故事。我们仍然在承认，比如，这件可怕的事情发生了。我不想让它发生在其他人身上。
I don't necessarily, I'm not grateful that it happened, but what are my cards now? And that's so much harder to face than the very simple, simple explanation of I'm just a victim, And these past circumstances are proof that I will continue to be a victim into the future. And there's no point wasting my time, wasting my energy, trying to change that. I hope you guys get where I'm coming from. I hope you can understand this isn't victim blaming. It's just a more nuanced discussion of like whether a victim mentality actually helps you. And when acknowledging circumstances and the role they play,
我不一定，我不感谢它发生了，但现在我手里有什么牌？这比那个非常简单、单纯的解释要难得多，即“我只是个受害者，过去的这些情况就是证明，我将继续在未来成为一个受害者”。把时间浪费在试图改变它上，纯粹是浪费我的精力和时间。我希望你们能明白我的立场。我希望你们能理解，这不是在责怪受害者。这只是对受害者心态是否真的对你有帮助进行了更深入的探讨。以及何时承认环境及其所扮演的角色
is valid and important and when it becomes a way to completely shield you or turn any form of agency invisible in your eyes. Okay, we've talked about ourselves, we've talked about the self-aware people who are critical of themselves when they fall into this mentality, know when they are adopting a victim mindset. Let's actually just turn back again to when that mindset is applied upon us by people beyond us, by parents, siblings, teachers, I don't know, friends, partners, colleagues, what do we do when we encounter somebody like that? When we have the self-awareness in ourselves to know that sometimes we do need a complaint, but this is maybe a level beyond,
是有效且重要的，以及它何时变成了一种完全保护你或让任何形式的自主权在你眼中变得隐形的方式。好了，我们已经聊过我们自己了，我们聊过了那些在陷入这种心态时会自我批评、知道自己何时在采纳受害者心态的具有自我意识的人。让我们再次把目光转向当这种心态被我们之外的人、父母、兄弟姐妹、老师、我不知道，朋友、伴侣、同事强加在我们身上时，当我们遇到这样的人时，我们该怎么办？当我们自己具备自我意识，知道有时我们确实需要抱怨，但这可能超越了这个层面，
what do we do about it? Okay, we're going to take another short break, but when we return, let's talk about, yeah, how to manage forever victims in your life. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently.
我们该拿它怎么办？好了，我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，来聊聊，是的，如何应对你生活中的“永远的受害者”。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中保持精神坚韧、体能和建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是
inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
会引起炎症的。我们弄错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day But just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack So I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So
我随时准备谈论快克，但为了让大家知道，我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病，所以
Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的，对我们来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾过去》在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts
Or wherever you get your podcast Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难地学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们仍在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变得只关乎输赢。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
完全同意。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。我是基尔·盖恩斯，欢迎收听我的全新播客《The hard way》（艰难之路），在这里我们将围绕疗愈、成长、为人父、压力与人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio 应用。
Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
搜索《艰难地学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。
sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上收听《爱情陷阱》播客，
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新季的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you've got a forever victim in your life, there's no one way to go about it, but here is perhaps the kindest way that you can that also won't drag you down with them. Obviously, it starts with this understanding of what's underneath. If we look past the words, the complaints, the despair, the blame, what we usually find is fear. For people whose victim mindset develop through trauma, this fear is learnt. It's a nervous system reaction. doing what it's always done for them, which is preparing for pain. And that is why logic, advice,
在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或其他收听播客的平台上收听。如果你生活中遇到了一个永远自诩为受害者的人，虽然没有唯一固定的应对方法，但这里或许有一种最温和的方式，同时也不会把你一起拖入泥潭。很显然，这要从理解他们内心的底层逻辑开始。如果我们透过那些言语、抱怨、绝望和责备去看，通常会发现恐惧。对于那些因创伤而形成受害者心态的人来说，这种恐惧是习得的。这是神经系统的一种反应，在做它一直以来习惯的事情，那就是为痛苦做准备。这就是为什么逻辑和建议，
pep talks aren't going to help. When someone's brain believes danger or disappointment is inevitable, that optimism that you would maybe use as a shield, like that's just not going to help them. The most powerful thing that you can do is in fact creating an atmosphere of regulation. That means staying calm when they spiral, modeling steadiness, showing them through your tone and presence that maybe this idea they have of themselves as a victim is not true and also isn't helpful. Compassion, you know, it doesn't mean that you have to just go along with it. You can validate someone's pain without validating the hopelessness. cycle or mindset that comes with it.
打气的话语都无济于事。当某人的大脑相信危险或失望是不可避免的时候，你可能会用来作为盾牌的乐观——那对他们根本没有帮助。你能做的最有力的事情，其实是营造一个调节的氛围。这意味着当他们情绪失控时保持冷静，树立稳定性的榜样，通过你的语气和存在向他们展示，也许他们这种认为自己是受害者的想法是不真实的，也是没有帮助的。同情，你知道的，并不意味着你必须盲目附和。你可以在不认同伴随而来的无望情绪。
You can say something like, that sounds so painful and I can see why that would hurt you, but I also believe that it's not always going to be like this. I also believe that there's a lot that we can do to change that. I also believe that things are going to still turn out okay as a way to model that this isn't the end of the world, and it also may not be what they think it is. Giving them a hint of like, hey, I, for one, believe you.
你可以这样说：听起来真的很痛苦，我也能理解为什么这会伤害到你。但我同样相信，情况不会一直这样下去。我也相信，我们有很多事情可以做来改变现状。我还相信，事情最终还是会好起来的。以此来向他们传达这不是世界末日，同时也可能并非他们所想的那样。给他们一点暗示，比如：嘿，我绝对是相信你的。
you have agency, invites them into a new story. Like a new version of seeing themselves that also accepts the past but doesn't tolerate this forever mentality that they can never change. So I think it's like you're safe but also you're capable. In therapy, I think this approach really mirrors something that we call motivational interviewing. Instead of arguing with somebody's self-defeating beliefs, you ask open-ended questions in this technique that help them discover their own reasons for change. You ask them, you know, what do you think life would look like if this pattern started to shift? What's one thing you wish you
你拥有自主权，这会引导他们进入一个新的故事。就像一种看待自我的新版本，它既接受过去，又不容许这种永远无法改变的受害者心态。所以我觉得这就像是，你是安全的，但你也是有能力的。在心理治疗中，我认为这种方法在很大程度上反映了我们所说的动机式访谈。在这项技术中，你不是去反驳某人的自我挫败信念，而是提出开放式的问题，帮助他们自己发现改变的理由。你问他们，你知道的，如果你生活中的这种模式开始发生转变，你觉得生活会是什么样子？你希望自己身上有什么是
felt different about? What's something small that you can do that you can control right now? Yeah, these circumstances are overwhelming. Yeah, it's really, really sucks who didn't get that job. Sucks that that person broke up with you. Let's think bigger. What's going to come for you next? What's around the corner that you're excited about? That is. second last one of what's something small you can control right now. I love that. I have a friend, Emma, she is a social worker and one of the most beautiful humans alive, but she, she uses this on me sometimes. I don't think I have much of a victim mindset, but sometimes, you know, I just, sometimes I like to whinge. And she tries to be sneaky about it, but I know
感觉有所不同的？有什么小事是你现在就能做并且能够掌控的？是的，这些情况确实让人应接不暇。是的，没能得到那份工作真的很糟糕。那个人跟你分手了真的很糟糕。让我们往大处想。接下来会有什么等着你呢？转角处有什么让你兴奋的事情吗？那是。倒数第二件是“有什么小事是你现在能控制的”。我太喜欢这个了。我有一个朋友叫艾玛，她是一名社工，也是活在这个世上最美好的人之一，但她有时会在我身上用这招。我不觉得自己有什么受害者心态，但有时，你知道的，我就是，有时我喜欢发牢骚。她试图偷偷摸摸地做这件事，但我知道
she does it, she has such a positive way of being like, let's redirect here. And it works. She doesn't have to do it very often, but it's so funny, I always call her out on it. I'm like, you can't, you can't therapies me. Like, I know what you're doing. And what these questions really do is, like, if you're somebody who can and wants to change, it just allows you to see that the door, the door is open. And it bypasses defensiveness by really just being like, here's an invitation. to take accountability. Now, for those of us on the other side, it's also crucial that you set boundaries around emotional labor, especially if this is somebody who is a family member or somebody that
她就是在这么做，她有一种非常积极的方式来引导话题：“让我们把话题转移到这里来吧。”而且这很管用。她不需要经常这样做，但太搞笑了，我总是当面戳穿她。我说：“你不能，你不能对我进行心理治疗。我知道你在搞什么鬼。”这些问题真正起到的作用是，如果你是一个能够改变并且想要改变的人，它只会让你看到那扇门，那扇门是敞开的。它通过直接传达“这是一个承担责任的邀请”来绕过防御心理。现在，对于我们这些处于另一端的人来说，围绕情感付出设定界限也至关重要，特别是如果这个人是你的家庭成员，或者是与你
you live with or somebody that you're very close with. Of course, I'm sure you love the people around you. You want them to feel great about themselves. There is a point where you cannot change them and it's not your responsibility and it should not drag you down. Endless sympathy does not work for people like this. Let's be very, very clear. And it doesn't help you either, even if you think you're being nice.
同住的人，或者是与你非常亲近的人。当然，我确信你爱身边的每一个人。你希望他们对自己感觉良好。但在某个时间点，你无法改变他们，这不是你的责任，它也不应该把你拖下水。无休止的同情对这样的人是没有用的。我们要非常非常清楚这一点。而且这对你也没有帮助，即使你认为自己是在做好人。
Boundaries are what keeps that relationship sustainable. Saying things like, I really care about you, but I cannot keep having this conversation because it's starting to hurt me too. Or I'm here for you, but I need you to take the lead on what comes next. I need you to really try and help yourself in this situation. Even saying things like, hey, I love you, but I can't be around this kind of negativity in my life because it's really starting to change how I see myself and I don't think that's good for either of us. These phrases signal empathy, but also an expectation that you need to take charge.
界限是维持这种关系可持续发展的关键。说这样的话：“我真的很关心你，但我不能再继续这个谈话了，因为它也开始伤害我了。”或者“我随时为你提供支持，但我需要你来主导接下来的事情。我需要你在这种情况下真正尝试去帮助你自己。”甚至说出这样的话：“嘿，我爱你，但我无法在我的生活中忍受这种负面情绪，因为它真的开始改变我对自己的看法了，而且我认为这对我们两个都没有好处。”这些话传达了同理心，但也传达了一种期望，即你需要掌控大局。
If you want me in your life, if you want this to be a positive relationship, something needs to change. I saw this beautiful quote the other day that said, true empathy is not about absorbing someone's feelings, but witnessing them without losing ourselves in the process. You know, it's very easy to think, I'm being empathetic when actually you're just taking the emotion away from them and placing it inside of you.
如果你想让我出现在你的生活中，如果你想让这是一段积极的关系，有些事情必须改变。我前几天看到一句很美的话，上面说，真正的同理心不是去吸收别人的情绪，而是去见证它们，而在这个过程中不迷失自我。你知道的，很容易让人以为“我在展现同理心”，而实际上你只是把情绪从他们那里拿走，然后放进了你自己的心里。
It's easy to think, I'm being empathetic when you're really, maybe by accident helping someone continue a cycle. when we over function for somebody else through rescuing, fixing, excessive, soothing, we actually reinforce their helplessness. We teach them safety exists through us and us only. And their sense or form of regulation becomes venting to us, becomes asking us to fix their problems, becomes complaining to us and knowing that we're going to be like, yeah, like, you're totally right about that.
当你其实只是——也许是不小心——在帮别人延续某种循环时，很容易误以为自己是在展现同理心。当我们通过拯救、解决问题、过度安慰来过度照顾别人时，我们实际上强化了他们的无助感。我们教导他们，安全感只通过我们存在，且仅通过我们存在。他们感知或调节情绪的形式变成了向我们倾诉，变成了要求我们解决他们的问题，变成了向我们抱怨，并知道我们会说：“是的，关于那件事你完全是对的。”
You are a victim. and you're going to stay that way. Like, that's not helpful at all. When we model stability, when we model boundaries, we teach them something subliminally. Now, sometimes despite all the empathy and all the listening, nothing changes. You know, some people just aren't going to change.
你是一个受害者，而且你会一直这样下去。听着，这根本没有帮助。当我们树立起稳定性，当我们树立起界限时，我们在潜移默化地教给他们一些东西。现在，有时尽管付出了所有的同理心和倾听，什么都没有改变。你知道的，有些人就是不会改变。
And that is like a really hard truth about life. Like, they're not going to change and they're not going to change for you. And that really sucks. And it's a really hard thing. to acknowledge, but you have to take the situation from there and just think about, hey, what's maybe best for me here? You'll know when it's time to kind of maybe distance yourself from a person, maybe see them a lot less, maybe limit interactions when compassion starts turning into resentment. Resentment is your body telling you that your empathy levels are sinking and they are sinking fast.
这就像是关于生活的一个非常残酷的真相。听着，他们就是不会改变，而且他们也不会为你改变。这真的很糟糕。这是一件非常难的事情去承认，但你必须从那里接手这种情况，然后去思考，嘿，对我来说什么才是最好的？当同情心开始变成怨恨时，你就会知道什么时候该和一个人拉开距离，也许减少和他们见面的次数，也许限制互动了。怨恨是你的身体在告诉你，你的同理心水平正在下降，而且下降得极快。
when you dread the next conversation, when you feel your body tense every time you see their name pop up, those are the signals that your boundaries are being crossed repeatedly, that this victim mindset is becoming contagious, and that you aren't feeling good about this relationship. It is a signal that your genuine desire to help has swiftly entered the territory of maladaptive people-pleasing. Sometimes in these situations, like walking away is the kindest thing you, you can do for both of you or giving distances is also a kindness so that this relationship doesn't end up just becoming a total like dumpster fire that again makes them feel like a victim. Giving yourself two weeks away from this person to see how your own life changes, whether you feel
当你对下一次对话感到恐惧，当你感觉到每次看到他们的名字弹出来时身体都在紧绷，这些都是你的界限被一再跨越的信号，这说明这种受害者心态正在变得具有传染性，而且你对这段关系感觉很不舒服。这是一个信号，表明你原本真诚的帮助愿望已经迅速进入了适应不良的讨好型人格的领地。有时在这些情况下，比如抽身离去是你对彼此能做的最善良的事，或者保持距离也是一种善意，这样这段关系最终才不会变成一个彻头彻尾的烂摊子，而这又会让他们觉得自己是个受害者。给自己两周时间远离这个人，看看你自己的生活有什么变化，你是否感觉
better is just a little experiment just so that you know your own limits and you are able to put healthy boundaries and distance between this person so that you can recuperate and so that you do have the energy to be around them for the good times as well as the bad times. If you need to distance yourself, do it with the clarity. Do it with clarity of like, I care about you. I want good things for you. Right now this dynamic isn't healthy for me. I hope you get the support you deserve. I'm so excited to see you soon, but I'm just kind of busy for the next couple of weeks and I just really need to recharge. I've got my own things going on. I'll talk to you when I get the chance. You know, it's harsh. It's probably something that not
好一点了，这只是一个小实验，好让你了解自己的底线，并且能够在这个人之间建立健康的界限和距离，以便你能够恢复元气，这样你才会有精力去陪伴他们度过美好的时光以及糟糕的时刻。如果你需要和自己保持距离，请带着清晰的认知去做。带着清晰的认知去做，比如：“我关心你。我希望你一切都好。但现在这种相处模式对我不健康。我希望你能得到你应得的支持。我很高兴很快能见到你，但我接下来几周有点忙，我真的需要补充一下精力。我有很多自己的事情要处理。等我有空了再和你聊。”你知道的，这很严厉。这可能不是
everyone is going to be willing or wants to do, but it's probably important to learn that you are allowed to just not be in somebody's life if they constantly make you feel terrible. And if you have done everything else on this list and this person does not change, brings you down, is using the victim mentality for manipulative purposes, you are allowed to change if they won't. And you're allowed to exit the relationship for self-care purposes and so that you can heal. The truth is, you know, this might sound like a simple situation. I'm talking about it rather than doing it. it's really complicated.
每个人都愿意或想要去做的事情，但学会这一点可能很重要：如果某人不断让你感觉糟糕，你是有权不出现在他们的生活里的。如果你已经做了这份清单上的所有其他事情，而这个人仍然没有改变、把你拉下水、为了操纵目的而利用受害者心态，如果他们不肯变，你是有权改变的。为了自我照顾的目的以及为了你能疗愈，你是有权退出这段关系的。事实是，你知道的，这听起来可能是一个简单的情况。我只是在谈论它，而没有真正去做，它真的很复杂。
You really just have to determine what's right for you, whether this person is a manipulative victim or a compassionate victim. It's really complicated. I feel like we like to just throw around these terms of like, that person has such a victim mentality, not realizing like that these people also have friends and family members and coworkers whose lives are intertwined with them. We need like a better way of dealing with it,
你真的只需要去确定什么对你来说才是对的，这个人究竟是一个操纵型的受害者还是一个有同情心的受害者。这真的很复杂。我觉得我们喜欢随口抛出这些词汇，比如“那个人有那么强烈的受害者心态”，却没有意识到这些人也有朋友、家人和同事，他们的生活与之交织在一起。我们需要一种更好的方式来处理它，
but sometimes like in the cases of control, in the cases where they're trying to guilt you or use your empathy against you, like you can just be like, this isn't what I want from my life, and you can provide distance and give yourself the distance to move away from that person. I'm giving you permission to say like,
但有时，比如在遭到控制的情况下，在他们试图让你感到内疚或利用你的同理心来对付你的情况下，你可以直接说：“这不是我想要的生活”，你可以拉开距离，给自己留出远离那个人的空间。我是在给予你许可，让你去说：
that's actually okay. And the severity of the circumstances may actually call, call for you to do that. You're not being cruel. That is the kindest thing you can do for your, yourself so that you don't turn into a victim who then ends up victimizing somebody else. And it's sometimes the kindest thing you can do for them as well. I hope this episode has given you a bit more to think about.
这其实是可以的。环境的严重性实际上可能要求你这么做。你并不是在残忍行事。那是你能为你自己做的最善良的事，这样你就不会变成一个最终反过来去伤害别人的受害者。而且有时这也是你能为他们做的最善良的事。我希望这一集能给你带来更多思考。
If you have made it this far, if you are a loyal, all the way through listener, I want you to leave a little black heart emoji down below. I think that's pretty symbolic, somebody who has a victim mindset. If you want to stay in the loop with other episodes that are coming out, you can follow us on Instagram at that psychology podcast and you can also follow us here wherever you're listening make sure you are subscribed please give us a five-star review if you feel cool to do so but if you don't that's all right as well i also want to thank our amazing researcher liby colbert for her contributions to this episode we couldn't do it without her and all of her help but until next time
如果你听到了这里，如果你是一个从头听到尾的忠实听众，我希望你在下方留下一个黑色的小爱心表情。我觉得对于一个有受害者心态的人来说，这挺具有象征意义的。如果你想了解即将推出的其他剧集，你可以在Instagram上关注我们：@that psychology podcast，你也可以在收听此播客的任何地方关注我们，请确保你已经订阅了，如果你觉得有必要的话，请给我们一个五星好评，但如果你不想的话也没关系。我还想感谢我们出色的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Liby Colbert）对这一集的贡献，没有她和她的所有帮助，我们是无法完成这一集的，但直到下一次
stay safe be kind be gentle to yourself good luck with the victims you're dealing with and we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。祝你应对生活中的受害者时好运，我们很快就会再聊。在《回顾过去》播客中。在1979年，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何挺过来的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《艰难地学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianney. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·米安尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and build up. and resilience in our strange modern world.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、体能和建立
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 TWA%，在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或其他你收听播客的平台上。当一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在任何你收听播客的地方。这是一档 iHeart 播客。由真人呈现。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。